hello how's everyone doing uh wow I look
uh younger there it's a few years ago I
guess but I am Michael Gibson uh I am
the co-founder of 1517 fund um we whoops
I had a uh Genera of AI develop some
images for what a network State College
would look like in the GU of Norman
Rockwell uh and I was asked to speak on
how to build a par institution to the
current University system I have some
background in this I thought it'd be a
professor of philosophy who was working
towards a PhD and I and I dropped
out um but even though I dropped out for
other reasons there were already
problems accumulating that we all know
about but just to rehearse you know
we're close to $1.7 trillion in student
debt in the United States people either
crippling under that debt or taking
well-paying but boring jobs to pay it
off it's a hot political
issue uh the cost of college over the
last 40 years has increased by more than
a th% and that's in real terms so it's
getting more expensive and people are
taking debt to pay for it and yet uh in
recent history even though College seems
to pay more than High School alone uh
nevertheless you know the incomes that
recent graduates earn aren't that much
higher and sometimes lower than they
used to be um so you know in technology
we're we're used to seeing better faster
cheaper uh with education and in
particular high red we have the opposite
things are getting more expensive uh in
some ways they're getting worse uh and
people are going into
debt uh on top of that if that weren't
bad enough now they've become uh in the
words apology woke
Madres uh there's indoctrination on
campus uh they tell you you can look at
the mission statement of any college
from Harvard on down and they will tell
you their mission is to help you to
think critically to become Leaders of
Tomorrow and yet uh here we have you
know most colleges you know some 4,000
colleges in the US and yet somehow
there's only one point of view um all of
this was you know it's certainly uh
trouble now but it was apparent that
this was a problem back in 2010
I was on the founding team of the teal
Fellowship I never thought I told you my
background I I never thought I would be
involved in the world of Silicon Valley
but I met Peter teal uh through potrey
Friedman who spoke earlier uh I
interviewed for a role uh on his hedge
fund he uh asked me if I would help him
teach a class at Stanford law school on
philosophy and Tech and I said yes to
that job because it was so cool uh but I
showed up to work the first day and I
can tell you the date cuz it was my
first day of work September 27th 2010 it
was a Monday I came to the office it was
exactly as you would imagine in a TV
show for a hedge fund uh there were
Bloomberg terminals stacked you know in
trip ticks uh there was a stock ticker
CNBC on the screen and I'm sitting at
this desk and I'm thinking how the hell
did I end up
here when my colleague Jim O'Neal came
to uh the desk and picked me up he said
hey we got to go to Peter's house I said
why he said well on the plane ride back
from New York last night we came up with
this idea we're calling it the anti-road
scholarship I said great I went to
Oxford that's where I dropped out of I
hated Road Scholars they were
insufferable credentialist Greyhounds
chasing mechanical lurs of
prestige uh so I was in I was like great
let's go what is this he's like well
we're going to pay people to leave
school okay great um so we we get to
Peter's house Peter comes bounding down
the stairs uh he gets you know his code
on his assistant is telling him the
schedule we get in a car it was uh Tech
crunch disrupt that day Peter was
scheduled to be interviewed by Sarah
Lacy and uh he had decided that this
would be the best time to announce this
program why well five days later on
Friday this is so long ago now the movie
The Social Network was set to come out
and in the script that had been leaked
by Aaron sorin you know Peter knew he
was going to be portrayed negatively uh
and certainly Zuckerberg was going to be
portrayed negatively and so he thought
he changed the conversation by doing
something bold so I'm in the car we're
like what do we call this thing we're on
our way to the convention center I'm
backstage you know people are trying to
pitch Peter their idea but we're
focusing on okay what do we call this
thing how much money Peter's on stage
and on YouTube you can watch the
interview uh if you find it and you will
see that Peter is talking in the present
tense he's saying we're taking
application we're running this program
it was already in
existence uh and so that was my first
day of work I went home and called my
parents I was like wow this is my first
day what's tomorrow going to be
like we there were two newsworthy
conditions for the
fellowship uh number one was you had to
be 19 and under to apply and number two
uh was that you had to not be enrolled
in school to rece received the
grant you know I I highly recommend
anyone here read the new Walter Isaacson
biography of Elon Musk but you can also
YouTube uh interviews with musk uh you
know the book is extraordinary Elon gave
complete access he even gave the emails
and phone numbers of his Ex-Wives and
girlfriends it's incredible really
gripping story but one thing that stood
out to me was something musk calls the
algorithm for this is how he thinks
about production assembly lines it's a
five-step process and the first step in
the process is uh what are the
requirements and challenge them so with
SpaceX there were all these components
and nothing had been innovated in
Aerospace in decades and they're trying
to drive down the cost of making rockets
and someone would say hey we need this
component because you know the NASA or
the military says it's a required
component and then he began to challenge
people find me the person who created
that component or who created that
requirement rather and then if there was
no good answer as to why it existed he
removed it and that's step two in his
algorithm if if the requirement can't be
justified remove it and he says you
never know if you're doing enough until
you put 10 till you have to put 10% back
in so I thought about this with respect
to the fellowship is that's exactly what
we did Harvard requires you to take 32
credits to
graduate some 16 in a major electives we
decided none of that is required to find
success in life especially when it comes
to working in technology but that didn't
convince anyone right away uh we had our
haters Jacob Weisberg took the Newsweek
and slate you can't see it in that text
but he said we were creating the white
man's version of the
NBA Harvard's uh former president Larry
Summers couple years later uh treasury
secretary of the United States He said
said and this is one of my favorite
quotes the teal Fellowship is the most
misdirected philanthropy of the
decade but now here we are 13 years
later what are the results young man
Dylan field created figma 2012 we helped
him launched it recently that made news
last year because they were bought by
Adobe for 20 billion doar uh just two
weeks ago atlassian bought loom for
nearly a
billion uh we helped vitalic launch
ethereum uh uh luminar went public
founded by Austin Russell multi-billion
dollar company makes uh sensors for
driverless
cars uh CB insights ran an analysis
recently on the teal
fellowship and you know this uh best
accelerated in the world not called y
combinator 11 companies worth more than
a billion dollars out of 150 teal
fellowships um pretty
extraordinary um you know Peter has a
famous interview question where he he he
he tests people by saying what truth do
you believe in that the rest of the
world thinks is false well I believe in
child labor is
good I wrote a book about this inside
account of the teal fellowship and what
we did uh originally a few Publishers
didn't want to publish it because I
quote literally one of them said uh
Peter teal is evil anyone who works for
him is evil uh and we can't pop possibly
published this you know six or seven
others said I went to Yale and studied
English literature I don't believe
this uh but nevertheless small
Publishing House encounter put it out I
think it's a hoot goes into some of the
background on on everything you just
saw so what's next in 2015 I realized I
could be uh making money and extending
the mission of the teal Fellowship I
started a fund called 1517 that's our
geeky historic reference to the
Protestant
Reformation um Martin Luther originally
nailed his 95 thesis to the church door
because he was protesting the sale of
indulgences and the Roman Church would
sell these they told you it could save
your soul uh if you bought one or your
friend souls and so we decided that you
know we don't believe in indulgences
there's a corrupt institution today
that's selling a piece of paper and
telling you it can save your soul it's
Yale or fail it's called the college
diploma and we think that's too
thank you
uh